hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
it has been a long time since I last
picked up the series and since then
there have been three count'em three
individual DLC packs releasing new
content about the story of this game and
a lot of you guys have been often asking
for me to play the DLC and I did not
know that there were three whole packs I
thought it would just been a small thing
but apparently these are full-fledged
parts of the story this one picks up on
Kidman and whatever the hell she was
hello
oh I thought those were I bow because I
know it has been a long time since I've
had an ongoing series and I figured this
one might be just the ticket to get
started back into those things yes yes I
know I did all this oh no it's so dark
is this one actually gonna be scary
one can only hope and I was playing it
to alien hand with Mobius I don't know
what Mobius is I made my choice okay
all right so where are we waking up oh
are we all the waiting back in the
ambulance
oh man it's amazing when I was loading
up this game it was it was rather crazy
how quickly all of it like came flooding
back to me when I was trying to think of
it and I can remember the entire game is
this a gratuitous ass shot is that
entirely necessary when we're loading up
on the female protagonists that we're
playing in the DLC how sexist is this
okay bye
all right whatever okay so uh what I was
saying before is that I was playing
alien isolation at the same time as this
and speaking a female protagonist but I
thoroughly white okay
oh I see how this is so each of them
woke up in different places remember
because they're all in Rubik mind if you
haven't seen the evil within I highly
recommend going back and watching it
we're going back and playing it for
yourself it might be on sale for the
Steam sale why I was complete I wasn't
alone yeah no you weren't alone buddy
those were all my questions when I first
loaded up this game a while ago am I
going the right way
man the controls seem just a little bit
different from what I remember I was
playing this with a controller last time
right that's that's fun also is it is it
just me or does it look a little better
too I have no idea
oh yeah going to the dark cave of
whispers it's what's-his-face Leslie
Leslie nose fixed and Jojo I'm gonna
meet Jojo again I can't wait to meet
Jojo again I hope he gets art poon
through his head again Oh
Hey so tetrakis gives a cream sauce
it didn't work but it was awesome
ow my spine Oh heal through the jaw okay
that was cool
come on you've been through worse you
know you know what's weird I remember
everyone else's name I don't remember
the main character's name when I played
him in throughout the entire thing of
evil within I just remember him as
cliche detective drunk dead wife no
family and [ __ ] I've gotta get out of
here no kidding Kidman I really and I
really wanted to know like what was
Kidman doing like why was Kidman having
her own objectives what was she pursuing
hello KCPD criminal record expunged
expunged expunged criminal trespass
grand theft
vagrancy shoplifting burglary possession
of controlled substances ill and assault
on an officer blah blah bad stuff
whoever's file this is what the hell is
that is this something I need to worry
about alright never mind then it's not
just me right this looks like a little
bit better be cold how I crouch again oh
god I got to relearn all the controls
well that's how I do a heel kick oh it's
right bumper what smells like blood
certainly not me the woman covered in
blood all righty then okay how I did
yeah oh that's how I do okay
okay cool I'm a backup to what the main
guy whatever his name is
it probably where's Joseph Joe do it's a
good assumption to make
yeah okay he'll kick my way through that
cuz I'm a strong independent woman oh
who the hell are you oh is that lovely
love life it's me don't run away oh
that's not Leslie that is not Leslie oh
it's one of the fascia cheese that's not
Leslie whole days Leslie sorry I'm just
a little bit too excited about this
hello Leslie Withers uh-huh
dad's not me
I'm sorry kid I need you focused I need
your attention
excuse me while I look over this matter
everything we do is a serious matter
you need to use Dave I'm ready I'd like
to think so but conviction must be
proven with action
as I was saying your target is Leslie
Withers he's a patient at Beacon mental
hospital but he's something more simply
put we need him to run our stem system
without this asset our research will
mean nothing I don't understand we own
beacon why not just take him our
relationship with his adviser Marcelo
Jimenez has become rather strained the
boy is a leverage piece a menace plans
to activate a stem prototype at beacon
without our permission obviously that's
unsuitable have no illusions it will be
dangerous come take a walk the nurses
are waiting
have no illusions is that like double
entendre going on there okay so what's
really interesting is that ants hello
cat
hi why do you have ribbon around your
neck that's symbolism or something
important or something I need to
remember this doesn't make a lot of
sense all righty then
I wasn't going anywhere oh oh the kitty
cats my save point cool oh that's
awesome okay right so what's really
interesting is that answers a lot of
questions because at the end of the game
it seemed to go crazy because obviously
we're in Rubik mind and things were just
falling apart everywhere okay can't see
your face something's weird about that
but all right whatever okay so like with
that being said the more interesting
thing was why was she here and why did
you wake up in a different place and why
was it all related and what was going on
that hospital in the first place like oh
the all those were questions that were
left open but I'm actually glad that
things are kind of being answered right
off the bat here like okay so she's
working for a company if you guys are
unfamiliar with like I there's gonna be
spoilers obviously if you haven't seen
the original evil within you're gonna
need to go back and watch it unless you
just don't want to hold earth I don't
want to hold if you don't want to get
spoilers then I'm sorry I can't talk
about the story without giving some
spoilers which I'll get back to as soon
as this guy goes up there's ask Elena
and probably talk something
if he minutes activates the system
you'll be called in wife Allah he
doesn't but as a precaution we've
prepared an infusion to prevent
contamination the source machine to
protect me more accurately to hide you
we develop staff but there is a ghost in
the system something we call ruvik means
to keep us out yeah I know some fusion
should protect you to some extent mm-hmm
so why did the other guy have to do all
the hard work unless I'm gonna find out
the Kidman was actually pulling a lot of
strings behind the scenes which would be
totally awesome and explain a lot of
what she was doing and why it was so
hard to meet up with her and why she
kept disappearing like that because
obviously the main character whatever
his name is
then captain detective you won't be
alone you'll be with your team from KPD
yeah the friendly Bunch
you'll get a call on the radio reporting
an incident at beacon everything will be
arranged
uh-huh but their consequences of little
fight in regards to your mission they're
expendable not quite from what I
remember click I'll get I'll talk to
more about this as soon as this is done
I don't want to miss seconds we must
have that boy he will enable us to
change everything you got it I'll come
back with him I needn't remind you the
consequences for failure Dan oil tea is
a sensitive subject for us Trust is such
a valued commodity in today's world
mm-hmm
so once again I ask you do you stand
with Mobius I do I made my choice mm-hmm
now you must back up your words with
actions
do not waver now I'm going to count down
and when I'm finished
I'll ask you a series of questions 10 K
9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
one
now I'd like to ask you some questions
Bandon by the ones you've trusted you
mean like right now gasp okay who's this
where I'm gonna inject brain juice into
me
probably that looks painful okay so am I
in the dream world now ow oh that
reminds me that I need to donate blood
soon okay I'm pretty sure that I'm in
the dream world okay so to recap from
what happened hello hi are you oh don't
mind me I'm okay alrighty then anyone
hey you weird
obviously monster guy you better run or
else I won't get you with my heel kick
that's the only thing I got right now
I bet I got some badass martial arts
moves but for right now I'm pretty sure
oh I'm just trying to explore around to
see ooh I need this flashlight yes I did
a goody
ok so finally I have time to talk so oh
maybe I was supposed to go this way okay
to recap what happened from the original
game and why I was so confused all the
time you were going through the whole
game as the main character but now I'm
starting to understand that the main
character actually didn't know anything
especially didn't know anything about
the game or the mission that Kidman has
and Kidman is obviously working for this
company that developed the system that
allows people to go into people's minds
and that's important because for the
story as a whole that makes sense but
where that falls short is that it counts
the story to be finished in DLC and I
don't know if that was done
intentionally to be able to sell DLC but
who knows like to be honest I don't mind
I'll have a better judgement at the end
of it all
hello does anyone need to be kicked here
I've got a mean kick waiting bow kick
okay just checking
okay that's script okay now I know where
oh I forgot the Sprint system sucks oh
this looks intense am I gonna be able to
do something about this
Wow geez Wow look at her
where the hell am I going now and also
am I is this still after the ambulance
or is this oh hey how's it going tonight
hold on I'm gonna find a way in there um
maybe I shouldn't because I got a bad
feeling about people with shadowy faces
was this this glowy important seems like
it
forgot about all the QuickTime events oh
yeah and what I was saying before about
alien isolation alien isolation I was
playing at the same I'm never gonna be
able to go through this long
huh are those the splattering sounds of
joy oh hi there
your heels are almost as nice as mine
okay that was weird
alrighty then anyway so what I've been
trying to say for the past 10 minutes I
was playing the evil within at the same
time as alien isolation and the
interesting thing about that is that
they get compared a lot what could have
done oh god I didn't even notice that he
didn't have his upper half well I think
the thing walking in stiletto heels
might had something to do with it also
he definitely had something to do with
it so when I was playing both of them
they got compared and admittedly I liked
alien isolation a lot more than I like
the evil within but that doesn't mean
that I didn't like the evil within the
evil within is actually a really good
game and I thoroughly enjoyed it it's
not a great game oh oh yeah I forgot
this cover system whoa
call enemy really I can call them I
didn't know about that the reason why I
liked alien isolation more if I can get
through a few more thoughts before
something distracts me again I hear
something
come here come here come hither he's
gonna go oh damn it okay I screwed it up
alright get a heel kick ha
kick ah Wow why are you glowing red can
I have your knife ah
you'll never get me oh I forgot the
melee is super weak ok that hurt a lot
please don't do that again
I'm not gonna be long ok I wouldn't be a
playthrough marklar if I didn't die and
suck right off the bat ignore that that
ever happened and I can finally finish
the thought but I was playing alien
noises hey Co what the Frick
oh I am never gonna be able to finish my
damn 400 afraid that the fragile mental
states of the subjects are limiting our
studies Mobius wants us to move past
beacon patients and on to more stable
people they want to get stem closer to
its intended use would they see the
world in the same way would a sane mind
whether the psychically training
experience I had that dream again I
entered the stem myself uh-huh
that's that doctor that didn't fare so
well in the first game okay I'm gonna
stay here and I'm gonna finish my damn
thought my God my face I want to talk ah
shop the problem with playing both of
them at the same time although it was a
great experience I'm really happy that
those two games came out at the same
time but the main problem that occurred
with that was that judgment spilled over
between the two and these games are very
different like very very different so
when I was playing them I wish I could
have given them more of an isolated
experience no pun intended for alien
isolation but I wish that I could have
done something a bit more robust in
terms of spacing things out like that
and I don't think it would like changed
my opinion of the games I still like the
games I think they're good games but on
a whole sense like having the to
experience blend together and also be
judged by everyone watching together at
the same time is gone or maybe not maybe
I did the thing again idak I can't get
there okay
we're gonna we're gonna do the shimmy
shuffle okay okay okay thank you
that we're done with fellas so easy why
did I whale on her with my heel when I
could just run through the door like a
big baby
hoosh ah there shoot a boost card out
and away okay yeah so that's what I was
trying to say about all that just that
I'm really glad that I was able to play
both at the same time and it's awesome
that I did but you know it would have
been would been much much more
interesting on a whole level her where
was that
wait am I going the wrong way okay all
right so now I'm actually gonna focus on
playing the game here because I was not
doing that oh yeah I should turn off how
do I turn off my flashlight oh that's
how I turn on my flashlight hey dude
what if I belt your right in the top of
the head yeah go in there go on there
baby
yeah yeah yeah that sure was a thing
over there okay now oh my me I'm just a
sneaking okay now we're going through
this I feel like something has changed
as far as a control scheme go because I
don't remember things going quite this
way imagine that I'll think okay so do I
need to go down to the door or do I need
to go down to the hallway why do I have
a keycard it's a good question hello
9-1-1 please yes oh I get it
I gotcha ah he should be in that
hmm should be quickly good yes what why
did here hey okay here we go okay got it
got it got it mash mash mash go go go go
go
yes i sooo like this introduction
because this introduction removes
weapons from me and the thing about the
first game is that it very quickly put a
gun in your hand and it very quickly put
the ability to fight in your hand I'm
not thinking that it's gonna completely
remove that whew
thank you from the equation here but
it's definitely good to start off a bit
slower it's actually interesting does
this this DLC is starting almost oh hi
hi there what am i oh I got the key
guard so oh I can't go through there
again uh oh yeah that's right no you
didn't see nothing oh now I won't go in
there come on
Jesus you didn't see nothing
hi mate oh yeah all that okay boy
thank you never come back
that is a interesting oh god I thought
it was gonna be the thing
what is this baloney this is malarkey
why are you why would you come in here
what are you doing what are you what are
you doing
I don't know what you're doing okay that
is all kinds of what are you doing what
what are you what are you doing why are
you sitting down all coward like you're
a strong independent woman
strong oh let me know that it I didn't I
didn't do did you do I've been to the
last print for two Saints member ha okay
I did not expect that to be there ah I
don't even know what that is I don't
even know what to call that
so I got the key card so I can go out
this door over here Oh Matt is mmm that
is disconcerting that is a terrifying
monster oh I apologize I'm sweating all
over the place it's not cuz I'm like I'm
super nervous it's really hot in here
right now and I haven't been able to
turn on the air conditioning in a while
I am just hello-o
oh oh god damn it
Oh [ __ ] I don't know why that got me so
bad he's absolutely nothing nothing to
worry about what's this why is this glow
green is this important
don't make anything glow green if it's
not important okay let's go damn it god
damn it with the hold terminated
authorization invalid gray could you say
that a little more sensually maybe I can
force it open with the computer
okay so this is why this is blue ticket
to get to get on the hacker I go to
hacker type down org CIA
crash FBI
Oh
we're what am i doing
okay thank you that thing used its light
oh that's so cool that's so cool oh man
what is this okay I'm hurryin is that
you Leslie okay who's in this box
what that was earlier in the first game
that I remember cuz I think Kidman was
trapped oh man I hope they never give me
a weapon oh really oh great good no oh
okay cool who's from before Leslie is he
really here yeah he might be you never
know these I'm glad that this facility
got all decrepid that's really cool I'm
so glad he is here okay I got to get to
him before anything else does yeah if I
recall how the first game goes that
never happens I really hope they never
give me a go hey are you a save point
look at you you're so adorable
oh man I wish I wasn't blathering so
much during this episode because I
wasn't able to get a good clear concise
thought through so hopefully hello oh do
I sit down all this so cool that's so
cool
least I don't need to self-reflect so
much oh do they
I really hope I never get a gun
throughout this entire DLC that would be
amazing
okay so that is the end of the first
part I'm gonna pick this up in 30 minute
episodes as I go along so I really hope
you enjoy the series I know I'm having a
good time this is a really great start
that was a terrifying enemy and it
actually is answering questions which is
all I ever wanted from the first game so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think of this in
the comments down below and if you got
any other games that you want me to play
let me know down there too
thanks again everybody and as always I
will
you in the next video
guys you want